a pocos kilómetros del caos de la
megalópolis amazónica la pequeña ciudad
de iranduba aparece muy tranquila aquí
las autoridades han impuesto un toque de
queda durante una semana desde las 2 de
la tarde las calles están desiertas el
hospital de la ciudad tiene el 90% de
sus camas ocupadas la situación es seria
para esta familia de comerciantes no
tenemos una unidad de cuidados
intensivos si la teníamos pero única
funcionó sin ninguna unidad de cuidados
intensivos y con más de 3400 positivos y
60 decesos en pocas semanas iranduba
hace todo para que funcione el
transporte público a maná o está
prohibido la patrulla sólo tiene una
instrucción tolerancia cero
tienes que ir a casa hoy te doy un
simple consejo pero si vuelve a suceder
serás detenido
por favor ponte esta mascarilla aquí
a los que nunca han padecido la
enfermedad en casa piensan que es una
broma que no hay proliferación del virus
así que es un trabajo duro pero sobre
todo educativo
el capitán no tiene intención de que su
ciudad sea contagiada por manaos
con todos los medios que tienen en
manaos están en una situación complicada
así que estamos haciendo todo lo posible
para evitar llegar a este nivel iranduba
ha logrado asegurar un valioso
suministro de oxígeno en manaus frente a
esta empresa privada a cientos de
parientes enfermos esperan durante horas
un recambio del preciado gas
miren los que puedan dejar sus tanques
háganlo por qué no podemos llenarlos
hasta mañana por la tarde una triste
rutina para el dueño desearía no tener
que llorar con todo el mundo
querida querida mía hoy no hay enemigo
amigo pues rico o pobre soy el proveedor
oficial del estado vecino
manaos ha tenido un contrato con otra
compañía durante 50 años
deberías preguntarles por qué hay falta
de oxígeno son una empresa multinacional
el mayor proveedor del mundo no había
razón para hacerle esto a nuestra ciudad
pronto serán las 7 de la tarde hora del
toque de queda rabia velina ha estado
esperando más de 8 horas no conseguirá
oxígeno para su padre esta noche
llegué a las 11 y me las arreglé para
conseguir una pipeta para salvar a mi
padre y a un amigo una experiencia
devastadora
[Aplausos]
experiencia devastadora
el gobernador de la región ha advertido
que hay que actuar rápidamente
autorizado tras semanas de suspenso la
vacuna china ha llegado por fin a la
capital amazónica